he's uh Reggie Miller reg will be on the
call for the Blazers Pacers that'll be
coming up Thursday at 8:00 Eastern on
TNT along with the award-winning Kevin
Harlan and Kristen Ledlow reg joins us
now I don't know what the feeling is
like in Los Angeles today reg this
celebration of life with Kobe and his
daughter at Staples what kind of feeling
do you think it's gonna be like there
well I think it's a chance for
especially the LA based fans the ones
who followed Kobe's journey as well as
his daughters it's a chance for them to
say goodbye it's this is a very
difficult thing to navigate because Kobe
is he was part of people he was a
people's person and this is a chance for
them to not only pay their respects but
to celebrate demand the young man that
he was when he came to them when he was
17 or 18 and then tragically left us at
such a young age so I'm sure be a little
bit therapeutic for a lot of people I
know they're expecting a lot of people
but I think this is a good chance for
people to say their goodbyes people here
are still processing processing this
loss here it's because you know I go
through days where you just shake your
head cuz you cannot believe it here it's
a little bit different I don't know
where it is around the rest of the
country but here is just people are
still a little bit in a fog or a daze
because they still just can't come come
to grips that that Kobe is gone on the
basketball floor who is better
offensively of anybody you were around
that I've ever played again yeah like
where does he fit into that conversation
oh he's I would say if him and Michael
were probably these my two him Michael
and Mitch Richmond were probably my
three the worst guys that I've ever had
to go again hmm all pose different
challenges
at that shooting guard position Kobe was
so complete he was a mirror image of MJ
in my opinion both strong quick athletic
the rock mitchrichman was a little bit
more physical had a little bit more of a
post a better post up game but those
three were probably my toughest covers
throughout my 18-year career yeah
because you know there's one thing
there's a lot of guys who have a lot of
talent but then there's that little gene
or characteristic that they want to they
want to kill you they they and you know
we saw that with Jordan I'm sure Byrd
had that as well I don't know if magic
had it Isiah at times had it like but
Kobe it felt like that was on all the
time it's like a nightlight that was
always on and it he couldn't turn it off
I try to tell people all the time
Michael and Kobe they wanted to
embarrass you in front of your family
and friends they didn't care it was
almost like they were missing that that
care gene with you and Cohen was very
much the same way MJ was a little bit
different away from the court once you
kind of got to know them a little bit
but on the court never showed you their
cards at all yeah I hope it's cathartic
for Laker fans because this is as you
said like you can't you can't be in Los
Angeles without feeling something seeing
something talking to somebody and the
fact that Vanessa and those three little
girls are gonna be there today and I
hope it's in some ways cathartic for
them as well but you know I love the
numerology that you have to for Gianna
and 24 for Kobe and to be able to
celebrate life which would be very
difficult but you know and everywhere
you drive around here and go there's
billboards
there's murals there's paintings
there's your posters there's billboards
all for Kobe and Gigi and let's say this
too and for the other seven that was
lost as well because we can't forget
about them so I think this is a
celebration really for all nine people
that were on that helicopter and it's a
chance in some small way for some people
just to say goodbye er to tell a story
or to have a brief encounter you may
have had with one of these nine people
it's a chance for you to say thank you
you know we praise and we will honor you
we will continue your legacy whatever
that may have been for you know any one
of these nine people but it's just a
great chance you know to hug one another
and you know while people are here we
need to be a little bit more accepting
and appreciate people here you know
because it happened so sudden a lot of
people didn't get a chance to really
tell Kobe GG is these other nine people
goodbye or what they felt I think this
is it's been a reality check for people
to start looking at people that are in
the present in the know now and tell
people how much you appreciate them
while they're on God's green earth
Reggie Miller on the call me
hall-of-famer he's got the game Thursday
night
Blazers Pacers did you watch the fight
oh who didn't yes I did I was a little
surprised I thought Tyson would end up
winning but I think he was gonna beat
him down like that I really did he said
you know what people forget is he's he's
actually a better boxer than don't say
well Wilder is a puncher fury can punch
you but he say he's pretty nimble guy
for being that big he's good boxer and
people did like for those who don't
follow the fight game Tyson Fury
footwork you know you mentioned boxing
his footwork is phenomenal and being
able because he knew one place could in
his day right so he was waiting for that
overhand right by Deonte but he jabbed
him to death broke his eardrum
through office equilibrium and the rest
was history and then like this again
that was a little bizarre a little crazy
even for Tyson Fury that was crazy I
went I think he just licked his blood
but he's a showman - all right I mean he
gets the you know he starts every fight
like the gladiators you know that the
whole chant he's kind of like that you
know get the crowd and you'll win your
freedom he got the crowd behind him you
know he came into this fight a star and
he left a superstar he is a superstar in
the sport of boxing now and I guess now
I guess everyone wants to see him in
Anthony Joshua I think that's the next
big fight unless there is a rematch
clause between Deonte and Tyson but it
was a good fight I didn't think he was
going to beat him down like that yeah
and then to see him have his corner
throw in the towel in the seventh round
switching to some basketball is watching
the Lakers and the Celtics yesterday
Jason Tatum is is the the star that
nobody talks about now he's getting a
little bit more attention here but it's
that position that gives the Lakers
problems there's two things that I
looked at yesterday that that talented
three that wing guy who can hurt you
inside and outside and also LeBrons
free-throw shooting he's still an issue
after all these years you got to make
these free throws because you're gonna
have the ball in your hands and do they
have somebody who can shut down lockdown
at least contain one of those you know
talented wing players and I think that
that's a big concern for the Lakers and
how far they go in the postseason your
thoughts and and think about Boston as
well because you mentioned Tatum but you
also have Jalen Brown and you also have
Gordon Hayward so you have three
talented wing players that are all long
athletic and can take you off the bounce
you know Tatum the all-star has played
phenomenal this pass I think he's
averaged 30 points over the last you
know this past month so he's Goodman he
always very good and now you can see why
Danny Ainge
that Celtic trust hung on to those
assets in him because he was going to be
part of that Anthony Davis potentially
being traded to Boston where you know I
think the Davis says look I'm not gonna
sign with Boston and that's probably why
it didn't happen but the Boston but here
here's the problem with the Celtics it's
not the Lakers how are they going to
solve that problem in Milwaukee and that
length we talked about the three lanes
that they have Canton a hat do they have
enough to get past that length and the
versatility of the Milwaukee Bucks it's
not the Lakers are worried about they
better be worried about that Greek freak
well also the Raptors have been playing
is go to basketball as anybody there's
seventeen and one since the middle of
January here and not that they're the
same as they were last year but they are
playing extremely well championship DNA
right everyone keeps counting them out
everyone's talking about Miami and
Milwaukee Boston rightfully so but the
end of the day there's only one team
that has the belt around their waist and
that's Toronto and they have shown that
and through all the they've had multiple
injuries this year two key players Lowry
Pascal Sayaka Serge Ibaka and Nick nurse
the head coach has found ways to
navigate this these guys understand how
to play well as a team and they just
pounded my Pacers last night into
submission I mean it wasn't even close
so keep sleeping on Toronto because
Toronto could be one of those teams I
would not be surprised if they could
upset
Milwaukee again now I know they don't
have the great colas or in Kauai but
collectively as a team they're as good
as they get all right if I said let's
have a draft on the teams that will win
the championship I give you the first
pick and I get the next - I'm going with
Milwaukee okay so your next two would be
I'm gonna take the Lakers and the
Clippers
and then I would probably go with
Toronto and Boston no no you don't get
two picks you get one I'll go with
Toronto all right so you got Toronto and
Milwaukee you got the East and I got the
West winning the champion I think the
three best teams are Milwaukee in the to
LA teams okay
but the problem is the two teams only
one one can come out well I thought
Joelle embiid is the best player in the
world according to Joel out but I
thought he was saying that he's among
the best players I like I looked at the
headline and I was like is he really
saying he's the best player I don't have
any problem if he says he's the best
like everybody was like oh my god he
said he's the best player I think I'm
the 14th best player in the NBA you
thought you were I mean if I said if
Billy wants to get back and we thought
Philadelphia was going to give Milwaukee
or run this season for that best record
in the Eastern Conference they've got to
get better on the road and I know what
people are trying to you know tear VIN
Simmons and Joe Elvin beat the first
concern is the back of Ben Simmons and
how long he'll be out I know he's yeah
getting an MRI they don't know how long
he'll be out yeah you get hurt at the
all-star game Ridge hey man I think he
fell and it was kind of quiet that he
got injured there and now of a sudden
it's sort of you know being brought to
light there but I got it I got another
question for you yes sir
I'm trying to understand why LeBron is
not going to win the MVP that it's going
to be Gianna's I think the top three
will probably be Yanis LeBron and
probably Luca Luca has missed some time
but in the American hasn't missed a beat
those are probably the finalists
LeBron's you know the last time LeBron
won the MVP the year yeah what six or
seven years ago I was 2013 2012 2013 he
was 28 the last time he won an MVP he is
certainly deserving of the MVP this year
him down a bit he's a great store I know
we love stories we've written the story
on Westbrook we've written the story on
harden we've written a story on the
Greek freak and now we can rewrite the
story on LeBron James got tons of
mileage there's no load management the
guy is out there playing leading the
league and assists and he has been a
he's been the best player on his own
team I as much as the Greek freak you
can say he's the best player in
basketball I have no problem with that
but LeBron you're better story you're
better furious LeBron yes I can't fault
anything you said right there okay but
if you're going strictly by numbers
you've got better numbers by the Greek
freak and he has the best record and has
a chance to win 70 games I know that's a
pretty that's a pretty good story as
well and and you like like LeBron no
load management has played what 90% of
the games this year and brings it every
day do you know that LeBron has played
three complete seasons of playoff
basketball games 239 playoff games so
when we say he's 35 he's not really yes
and he's doing this at a still at a high
level against guys who were 10 years
younger than him agree I know I just
love this story we love the story and
speaking of which Zion Williamson could
did we underestimate I win the Rookie of
the Year next year but he has proved a
lot of people including myself wrong
well I just didn't I wanted to maybe
temper the expectations for him because
it felt like they were unfair and
I was trying to protect him in some way
I don't know but I thought you know what
if he puts up Julius Randle numbers of
twenty and ten that I would love that
and now it looks like twenty and ten
come on
yeah you got to be kidding me I want him
to get to the finish line so there's
still what 25-ish games to go and he win
the Rookie of the Year no no you just
can't come in you know he's only played
a month
work a month's worth of games here John
Marantz been around since the end of
October so linen I just think you know
how I'm just throwing it out there rich
he deserves it
John Moran has been great and and but
but Zion if he continues to do this for
twenty more games
he won't play twenty more games because
they will advantage him all right come
back to backs left in there so you won't
play what if they make the playoffs and
they and they beat Memphis out for that
eight spot and bake the playoffs and he
continues to play like this Zion is our
Rookie of the Year I'm going with that
reg will be on the call with Kevin
Harlan Kristen Ledlow that'll be
Thursday it will be the Blazers and the
Pacers Reggie goes back home to Indiana
where is your Jersey where's your Jersey
in the building I believe it may be next
to uncle Mel Daniels I know it's up
there yeah all right our mr. Roger brown
see all is either uncle Mel or mr. Roger
brown you got to respect your ABA elders
they paved the way for a lot of us now
it where is Travis best uniform compared
[Laughter]
underneath Austin Crozier's Jersey
[Laughter]
my fellow teammates there Theodore yeah
and maybe if I put both Davis brothers
together maybe I woulda had a complete
player well I will say this the Davis
brothers they protected you yes they did
they should be having his number retired
up there there's a lot of great pacer
players that numbers need to be in the
rafters as well no didn't-didn't Travis
best scorer 81 points in a high school
game he did he was Kobe beef or Kobe
ball hog what's wrong with guys getting
like record number assists in high
school you guys always 36 in 32 minutes
that's it well I didn't play 30 32
minutes
I played less than that and there's no
3-point shot okay so did this come from
outside of course it did I was known as
mr. outside in high school I was mr. way
outside reg okay no they know because I
tell them all the time yeah they know
way too much they know more than they
want to I'm mister way outside
I like that mr. way outside thank you
for having me thank you all right Reggie
Aloysius Miller jr. the third for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]